Apollo Costa would be an amazing fight I  think I think he's very dangerous he's  the most powerful of those three Nate  Diaz he's a pepper guy from the outside  he's got his range Jake he fights very  scared I don't know how scared he would  be of me I'm not Anderson Silva so I  might catch him with some good shots  that could put a hurting on him but  Paulo Costa I like Paulo  um he's very  physical looking guy very strong and I  think to box him I would have to use a  lot of speed and skill a lot of  technique and I would have to trick him  and make him run into some good shots I  don't know if I could knock him or hurt  him too badly but I could out Point him  [Music]